[Música]
quiero parir en casa porque quiero parir
mi nombre es si se dan en google desde
los 7 años he visto que mi madre sale de
su casa atender partos mi hermana
lisette quiñones sánchez desde los 11
años ayuda a niños ya niñas a llegar al
mundo
mi madre junto con más de 200 parteras
hace más de 30 años fundaron la
asociación de parteras unidas del
pacífico' a su par upa
yo tengo 37 es toda una tradición es mi
linaje y es mi tradición también
como perdón acá no
adelante y atrás qué pasa acá
[Música]
ok acá vamos yo creo que falta una
diapositiva porque lo que quería contar
acá es porque no pude parir y es que a
mis 25 años tuve la oportunidad de estar
embarazada vivía en bogotá y durante el
embarazo desarrollo de prec lancia
el tema de la presión arterial y
proteínas en la orina eran el tema del
día a día con el médico realmente
es decir que no podía parir y la opción
que tenía era una cesárea efectivamente
lo que hicimos fue estabilizar me y con
el tiempo madurar los pulmones de mi
chiquita hasta programar la fecha del
nacimiento
cinco años después estaba viviendo en
buenaventura y volvió a quedar
embarazada por mis antecedentes médicos
tenía que volver a la clínica cuanto
antes porque sabía pues que tenía este
riesgo del apec lancia fui donde el
médico y le dije yo ya estoy cerca
buenaventura si con mi mamá yo quiero
parir en casa el médico fue rotundo y me
dijo no se te puede romper el útero
estás loca no puedes parir en casa
tienes que hacerte una cesárea
para mí fue super difícil fue bastante
triste pero bueno yo dije si este médico
me dijo eso yo no me quedo yo voy a un
segundo médico en igual de condiciones
de una muy prestigiosa clínica también
aquí en cali y fui y le dije doctor yo
quiero para ir en casa que tengo que
hacer el médico me dijo mira por los
antecedentes médicos hay que hacer
muchos cambios tenemos que arreglar
porque toda la gestación esté
normalizada pero lo que sí quiero
decirte es que hay una posibilidad pero
tienes que parir aquí en la clínica en
la casa no el riesgo es muy alto
entonces bueno al menos esta opción me
dejaba un poco mucho más optimista
porque ya no era el tema de que se
pudiera romper el útero siendo así lo
que hice fue prepararme para parís lo
primero que hice fue cambiar todos mis
hábitos alimenticios hasta el día de hoy
soy pesca tarja como solo vegetales y
pescado luego decidí irme a brasil
estaba ya casi de 6 meses de embarazo
acá está con mi hija sofía que es mi
compañera y mi coequipero no me acompañó
fuimos a brasil a un curso allá
estuvimos meditando empoderando me y
también tuve el contacto con una partera
que también me estaba acompañando y
apoderándose de que yo podía parir que
pudiera parir en casa y que incluso no
necesariamente la manera tradicional con
las que parimos para las mujeres que
está acostada y que sale de allí
las mujeres tenemos una cavidad vaginal
diferente y yo de acuerdo a mi cavidad
pues si va a parir en cuatro no acostaba
como es la manera tradicional entonces
esto me generaba mucha mucha posibilidad
y estaba muy contenta porque yo sentía
que iba a poder conseguir mi deseo de
parir en casa
y entonces estuve
así que 21 días en nuestra aldea allí
estuvo empoderando me y al regresar a la
casa desafortunadamente también en ese
momento mi matrimonio tampoco daba
cierto emocionalmente me estaba
afectando no no no no no apoyaba
inclusive el parto y también decidimos
divorciar entonces me divorcié a los 7
meses y a partir de ese momento dije
bueno debo seguir con el empoderamiento
del parto y lo que realmente para mí
significa volver a renacer y volver
realmente cuando nosotros como mujeres
tenemos un hijo relajamos pero también
damos la posibilidad de que lleguen al
mundo de la manera natural entonces
comencé a hacer programación escribir
por todas las partes de mi casa island y
va a tener un parto amoroso feliz
completo y saludable lo escribía en el
baño lo escribió en la cocina en la
nevera en el comedor por todas partes
también grabé en mi voz comencé a
desprogramar
y sean y no necesita sentir dolor ni
dificultades durante su parte island y
tendrá un parto amoroso feliz saludable
y completo así y escribía todas las
noches hasta lograr hasta que llegó el
primer día de trabajo de parto cuando
llamé a mi mamá dije mamá mamá creo que
rompí fuerte
mi mamá y mi hermana se desplazaron a mi
casa en mi casa estaba mi hermana perdón
mi hija estaba una duda que había venido
de brasil a acompañar mi parto las
esperamos y empezamos todos contentos el
trabajo de parto entonces estamos muy
contentos ya pues se sentían las
contracciones y empecé nosotros cuando
empezamos trabajo de parto
empezamos a dilatar y tenía dos de
dilatación y bueno todos felices en mi
oficina conté que estaba en trabajo de
parto todos felices me llamaron y les
encajó el parto pero llegó la noche y me
pare no avance el segundo día
no soy muy buena manejando esto acá
porque está como santiago porque iba al
primer día
el segundo día realmente lo que pasó fue
que
no hace mucho y me llamaban demasiado ya
estaba un poco estresada porque la
presión de que me voy a parís ella nació
la bebé que hoy aparece yo no no ha
nacido pero porque no ha nacido que está
pasando yo no lo ha nacido entonces me
cansé de poder contestar y dije no
quiero más teléfono no quiero contestar
no quiero nada y realmente no avanzaba
entonces así hasta que llegó el segundo
día y ya el tercer día dije voy a ir a
donde el médico a ver que lo que está
pasando yo madruga fui y me hicieron un
monitoreo cuando llegué a la clínica me
dice la doctora pero por qué no hacemos
una cesárea usted porque está en un
trabajo de parto de casi tres días
porque no programamos son necesarios
doctora es que yo quiero parir pero es
que esto está pasado de moda pero es que
esto duele es que para la mamá es muy
difícil es más usted se ve estresada y
yo me dije bueno pero
dónde está el respaldo médico frente a
mi decisión como mamá que quiero parir
efectivamente lo que hice fue
antes de empezar mi trabajo de parto y
bajo mi nueva vida de madre soltera yo
tenía un carro chiquito y había decidido
cambiarme a un carro grande para que mis
hijas estuvieran mucho más cómoda
entonces pero dije lo voy a retirar
cuando ya cuando ya termine todo mi
proceso de parto ante la noticia de que
estaba estresada que que nada que
necesitaba cambiar la pensión que mi
foco tenía que cambiar
bueno decidí ir con mi hija y aquí
estábamos fuimos a concesionario de
tercer día trabajo de parto a recoger el
carro
llegamos allí y yo le dije al asesor ahí
es que yo nunca manejaba una camioneta
usted es tan amable y me lleva a dar un
paseo y me explica cómo manejar una
camioneta entonces lo que harán señores
ya ni vamos y nos fuimos a la zona rural
y el limpio y bailaba y él iba indicando
me mire esto es así eso sacan arena
hasta que llegamos a un río digamos al
río y todos nos metimos la parte de la
duda que también era psicóloga esta duda
me la mandaron del cielo maravillosa
porque la psicóloga romà terapeutas que
tenía todo entonces
y nos metimos al río y empezó a ser un
ritual él le pidió a las diosas que me
ayudaran con el parto que me
tranquilizara que yo se focalizará
volviera a reconectar para poder tener
el parto y bueno nos montamos otra vez
al carro pero esta vez yo iba manejando
ya sabía cómo manejar cuando llegamos a
casa le dije el acceso es que yo estoy
en trabajo de parto
esto hace que le vaya muy bien en su
parte hasta luego
yo me subí
estuve tranquila pero no avance
realmente me quedé allí y el ansia del
otro día ya estaba relajada ya era de
cuarto día y madrugo mi papá y mi mamá a
la casa mi mamá estaba problema iba y
volvía pero ya mi papá que es como mi
figura no llegó y difícil ya estamos muy
preocupados llevas casi cuatro días en
trabajo de parto a nosotros no nos
parece esta situación no es tan normal
nosotros sabemos que un trabajo de parto
son nada más máximo dos días pero ya son
cuatro días yo dije bueno yo voy a ir a
donde el médico a ver cómo está la bebé
y bueno vamos a averiguar y pues sí pues
sí tengo que mirar la opción necesaria
pero pues yo voy y efectivamente pues yo
fui el médico me hizo un monitoreo y
adivinen qué me dice
no está usted le falta tener relaciones
sexuales
es que necesita el semen para que pueda
dilatar y yo decía dios mío pero yo sí
sé acaso un acuerdo del nombre de papá
de mi hija
y por dentro sean relaciones y estaba
separada de los siete embarazos pero yo
quería partir así que yo llamé
utilizando esta opción hola es que mira
yo necesito parir
yo recuerdo que era muy bueno
y para él era muy extraño que yo la
llamara porque de verdad que yo no le
hablaba muy mal de dos meses sin hablar
pero él ni siquiera sabía que yo estaba
en trabajo de parto si tú me haces este
favor
pero yo necesito parís el tiempo estaba
en nuestra ciudad así que hasta la
medianoche ya estaba en buenaventura
nos vimos en un hotel es pues bien mi
familias
y yo hay a mi juicio de haciendo la
tarea y regresé a la calle
pues me diría la casa mi familia está en
una junta familiar diciendo pues porque
igual y me haya salido y qué era lo que
había pasado
entonces no había ni mismo más ya estaba
pero nada más ya quién se le parece que
a la hija la partera le pase algo no no
no irían yo creo que ya tenemos que
mirar la opción necesaria
entonces yo me sentía con los
superpoderes del parto yo decía entre
miramos entonces hagamos una cosa si yo
hoy en la noche no no no no par y no
paro no no no tengo el parto al otro día
yo voy y hacemos la cesárea pero
esperemos esta noche
y de verdad yo les decía precisa el
semana cayó puesto así no
y de la mañana pero desafortunadamente
llegó el sol y yo no parís
así que me sentí muy triste lloré tirada
todo coloca la maleta y yo soy muy pero
porque yo hago esto yo subí cerca porque
me pasa esto pero porque yo estoy aquí y
efectivamente me fui a la clínica y
llamé a un amigo y le dije efectivamente
que la que me acompañara para yo irá a
cali pero que quería pasar primero a la
clínica local para que me diera las
condiciones médicas de mí sic de mi hija
y yo fui y el médico me hace un
monitoreo y el monitoreo estaba bajito
entonces me dicen mira tú has comido y
yo no a bueno ve a desayunar y vuelves
te hago la orden de hospitalización
porque tampoco puedes viajar y hacemos
la cesárea aquí entonces yo había ido
con mi mamá y mi hermana y la duda
entonces volvimos a la casa me comí todo
con todo como nunca y social esto
convirtió como nunca
comí demasiado
y regresé a la clínica cuando regrese a
la clínica me volvieron a hacer el
monitoreo
y la bebé ya estaba mejor entonces él me
comió mira es que tú no hayas comido
cuando uno come
se baja la pulsación yo ya me sentía más
tranquila pero él me dijo ya que vamos a
hacer orden de hospitalización te vamos
a hacer la cesárea aquí vamos a empezar
trabajo elige doctor pero es que yo
quiero parís mi bueno hagamos una cosa
y esperamos un rato si tú no logra subir
la dilatación
hace necesario pero si no hacemos el
parte equina clínica acuéstate te ha
gustado y una que usted señora yo
haciendo el tacto estaba acostada cuando
me dice espera un momento porque un bebé
estaba por nacer
entonces yo claro y la señora ya estaba
pues preparó el médico fue yo no cuente
diez minutos y el bebé nació cuando el
bebé nació y comenzó a llorar mi hija se
comenzó a mover fuerte muy fuerte y yo
me puse de pie pero qué pasó acá porque
ya casi no se estaba moviendo en
sucesión de gente y yo dije doctor yo
necesito ir a mi casa y mi señora o sea
está hospitalizada gana a su marido para
que le traiga la ropa y yo prefiero
tengo marido es que yo no tengo a nadie
y no señora porque usted tiene aquí está
ya hospitalizada
si bien mire doctor
yo necesito ir a mi casa no tengo a
nadie él está viajando entonces si usted
me deja ir a mi casa yo me voy caminando
y mientras camino puedo dilatar y al
regresar pues miramos si yo he aumentado
para que me haga el trabajo
trabajo de parto o si no me hace una
cesárea pero yo necesito ir a mi casa y
así muy fuerte
ok vayas y yo me fui a la casa
llamé a mi mamá a mi hermana a la dula y
al tío último que estaba ahí acompañando
me encerré en mi cuarto yo le dije ya me
hicieron el monitoreo y todo como salió
bien
pero voy a parir aquí en casa y mi
familia como yo sí voy a parir aquí en
la casa nomás de annie pero es que yo
soy cansada y annie pero mira pero es
que ya mucho tiempo y estaba dilatando
mira lo que llevamos la mamá tú eres la
mejor partera tú vas a la calera a
atender partos y yo sé que lo vamos a
lograr
voy a parir aquí en la casa yo me voy a
poner unos tenis voy a salir a caminar y
a regresar comenzamos el trabajo de
parto
entonces ya muy seria muy empleará a mi
mamá mi hijo bueno listo usted lo quiere
así lo vamos a hacer así si yo me fui a
caminar mi tío me decía usted es
igualita a su mamá cerca de mí y yo me
fui y cuando regrese a la casa yo ya
estaba en tres de dilatación y mi mamá
dijo ok vamos a comenzar el trabajo de
parto yo comencé y ya empecé a subir yo
en tres viven cuatro y yo estaba y me
duele y yo mamá mamá esto me está
doliendo más pero quiere parir que ellos
sí sí sí sí se iba para el baño y yo
sentía que todo se me iba a salir por
allá
duele mucho
pero usted quería ir a la clínica y así
y cuando estaba en medio del parto
cuando llegué a mi papá yo me había
soñado con mi papá que llegaba a mi
parto y que era un parto familiar pues
cuando yo lo vi yo dije yo voy a parir y
digo mi papá yo ya estaba en 9 y la
canción después del día 10 cuando mi
hijo web llegó la hora y nos fuimos al
cuarto me acosté como ya me ha dicho la
partera de brasil en 4 y empezamos mi
mamá ya ni mujer y mujer hija tú eres la
mejor tú puedes y yo ya estaba muy
cansada cinco días de trabajo de parto
de han sido súper difícil y mamá mujer y
un momento que puse tan fuerte que mi
hija nació
e
y aquí está mi mamá con mi chiquita en
la calle
la vida
el parto es un proceso patológico no es
un proceso patológico sino fisiológico
para ir es un proceso de catarsis
emocional tan natural y yo los invito
hoy esta noche aparte de contarle esta
historia a que apoyemos la ley del parto
humanizado es una ley la ley 063 que
concursa en el congreso de la república
y yo les invito a parir los invito a
apoyar el parto y hacer de ello un
momento sagrado humanizado y respetado
[Aplausos]